welcome to this video the start of a new
series like many other serious that I'm
starting at the moment yeah this is
called chess Giants was looking for
title there the main point of the series
is to present great games from the past
that the play Barney brought champions
other strong players but should be
classic classic games older games but
games to enjoy spectacular games
it's about loading some things but also
enjoying those great games yeah I'm
going to present games from from from
all ages of chess from the from the last
century but even though the stuff maybe
I get in some game film from Stein it's
on Murphy at times but okay I'm just
going to start with the very spectacular
game played by me
behold tall on the white side and vasily
smyslov on the black side so we're
starting with two world champions at the
time this game was played as 1959 yeah
both them were competing for the title
of world champion in a way by
participating in the candidates
tournament that was held in some various
cities in Yugoslavia Yugoslavia
smooth slope at the time was the ex
world champion he lost the title to put
Vinick in a return image I think the
year before 1958 57 one of those and
tile of course was a young player 22
years old and his he yeah this was a
typical type of yeah rising like a
comment I think it's the expression it's
playing this protection attacking chess
yeah both certainly wanted the title
match and we got a great fight in this
game Tom played 1e form he played all
opening moves but he fought was his main
move especially in the younger years c6
d3 interesting talus playing an on
theoretical move in a way not going for
a quick deform d3 is very often leading
to positions typical of the Kings Indian
attack for example d3 that he played the
d5 Spurs love 92 now this must have
played e5 occupying the center if black
plays something like this for example we
can easily get the position that
resembles a reversed King's Indian with
e5 however player gets some somewhat
distinct character Knight f3 attacking
on e5 and Knight to d7 yeah this
nowadays is not played so often not a
bad move but it's a bit a bit less
common nowadays Bishop d6 has become the
it has become the main line here after
which white can continue you know in a
slow fashion like Bishop e3 or g3 but he
also can play deform funny-lookin with
this loss of the tempo but it leads to a
decent structure for white for example
something like that can happen which
resembles the French tarish in a way
with black losing this d4 pawn back and
then we have an IQ p position isolated
queen pawn in the game he played 97 and
here also deforms played I think this is
a pretty remarkable move because it
shows that tom was taking a very very
concrete approach to chair to chest
which was a bit new at the time
newest may be a strong word but tower
was in a way yeah I'm a bit of a pioneer
if you look at chess as you're looking
at chess as a more mathematical or more
calculating thing then he was a pioneer
in this in this aspect he looked more at
concrete things happening as other
players who more were more concerned
about about general consideration in
this case deform it looks like in loss
of a temple but for concrete reasons
it's a good move at a tech c5 and yeah
what what should like do probably in
this position he takes deform is the
more reliable move he took on e4 and the
game but taking on defaults may be more
reliable as mentioned why should take
and then we get a position that is
comparable to other
iqp positions something like this and
probably probably black has nothing
particular to fear in this position what
it's not very much ideal is this night
on d7 you rather have it on c6 but on
the other hand black does not have any
any bad peas or a big problem of course
the pawn is is slightly weak but that's
not the end of the world he took on
deform
after which Knight takes e4 is played of
course and he'd like again as this
problem that a five is attacked and he
don't really have a good way to protect
the pawn so he decided to capture and
now the Queen captured and it's quite
funny White has somehow a loss to move
with d3 d4 it looks like loss of a move
but still a has got the better
development quite quite remarkable
Knight f6 Bishop g5 not losing any time
just developing very very quickly
Bishop e7 here we come to a very typical
situation here tile has a choice he has
two good moves he can castlelong this is
what he did
I can play 96 and I'm quite sure the
more technically focused player would
probably have preferred 96 96 this is
simply strong for white like mistake
Queen takes and now probably 94 this is
the move that black probably must play
otherwise his even more trouble and
takes takes Bishop d7 94 and now
probably just should be 2 and in this
position or maybe 92 is Sam the question
at this position white is distinctly
better he's got two bishops in an open
position and he will torture black 4 for
ages for example I am willing to take a
small bet here that probably a player
like Fischer would have played 96
getting the bishop am getting a
technical position which is totally
one-sided
well tile is preferring to play a play
for the attack on plays long castles
which is a good move
absolutely no one no argument but it is
less clear less defined than 96 long
castles yeah black castle short and now
we put the knight only 6 not a bad piece
it's a very annoying piece on d6 the
knight is very very problematic for
black and white also has this idea black
now played Queen to a5 in order to
control their 5 square here also could
have played Knight b6 maybe this was was
a good alternative
nothing great for like but maybe this is
more solid this Bishop is now covering a
five wide of course can always take and
sort of play a position like that again
an open position with the two bishops
but maybe this was was easier to play
than the game Queen eight five forever
it's not a mistake not a mistake it's
just a much much more complicated yeah
tortuous them I guess the best move
Bishop c4 quickly developing all pieces
should be developed and also get towards
this point on f7 black played b5 and Tom
played Bishop 52 attacking the Queen
yeah like some blacks queen is attacked
why should it go there's really only a
six yeah if we we go back let's say to
d8 that black must also reckon with the
capture on f7 this is also a case um in
the game but the Queen is I think better
placed on a six well he went to a a
six-night f5 back attacking the bishop
twenty seven eight black now has a big
choice and it's a quite remarkable that
so early in the game we have a big
crisis the bishop is attacked where
should it go
I think black mostly has two moves to
consider Bishop to d8 and played in the
game or Bishop c5
yeah Bishop c5 leads to amazing
complications it's of course comparable
to what happens in the game to the
bishop is of course a bit more active on
on c5 at least it appears to be more
active Queen h4 of course this
what what probably should do queen f4
also interesting but Queen age for us
probably more obvious yeah now we need
to check what happens if black takes the
piece it's a piece sacrifice after all
yeah what does why do now the strongest
mafia is Bishop to c3 just a silent move
setting up this Bishop on the long
diagonal let's check what happens if
white plays differently
you can't play Queen g5 here but after
98 it is not clear what white is doing
next that's a big difference to their
game where the bishop is on d8 and where
white could just take the bishop now we
would see this later with the Bishop on
c5 Queen g5 does not really do anything
good but Bishop c3 is in fact the strong
move White has the time to approve this
piece what should like do yeah black
really does not have any any slow moves
and he cannot just play random move and
and be okay White's the tech assembly is
too strong for that so let's say people
play something and who create it so
example yeah
after this move white is winning
immediately with loop takes d7 that's a
very strong move if now the knight takes
we're going to win immediately Knight g5
attacking one h7 Black has absolutely no
defense against that there for example
Knight f6 yeah white can take on g7 if
you take here there's this move coming
not a good idea but Knight x g7 is going
to go in to win this very quickly the
rook hangs the knight hangs if black
takes track checkmate it's a direct mate
there's a fantastic attack that black
ass is unable to unable to cope with
black absolutely should play a forcing
move queen takes a - that also gets
Queen a one check into the equation very
important it's not like not to the pawn
but it's the counter ideas against the
king that I pawned yeah what should Y do
there is no time for anything anything
snow so it's Bishop it's route xt7
amazing stuff the same idea that we had
before
yeah now it's easy Bishop d7 Jack gets
killed immediately very nice yeah this
leads to a checkmate
black only have some some spy checks
here but he cannot prevent this
checkmate if black goes to a Jade wide
wins with Queen f6 also very nice
checkmate
enter mate and black has no counter
chances again just that this is just
some of the Queen f6 just a spy check in
so after rook d7 Bishop d7 not working
at all what about 97 after 97 white also
wins with ok here there's more than one
good way qui G 3 is also strong but what
can also play Queen h6 which is simply
fantastic am taking checkmate these are
made and black has no way to cover g7
only some spy checks again so after rook
d7 it's amazing black can now cannot
take one of those pieces
what is blacks best Leafeon and there's
only an absolutely amazing resource him
- before this is a move that in fact
black can still play it looks totally
crazy but it's the only move that
continues the game the idea is that
after white takes on before the bishop
is driven away from the long diagonal so
black actually can take on d7 without
without losing immediately there are
some interesting lines here of course
instead of Bishop before white can also
play the check on h6
yeah let's start with this check check
on h6 it starts with this if black takes
check we're going to meet him very very
quickly even made next month yeah
checkmate the rook is blocking this not
easy to see okay
so King h8 must be played after the
check and now what should why do ya
probably Bishop takes before it's not
possible anymore to win in in
spectacular fashion because black has
some counter threats yeah this for
example is itself made not a good idea
and this formerly spectacular move is
not winning anymore
it looks very nice but after this in
fact black can take because Bishop f6
it's not possible it's a pin here it's
funny what can track still continue all
this with Knight takes f7 and everything
is hanging a very typical of Tao King g7
rook takes a one Bishop d7 Bishop before
Luke f7 yeah and this is a very long
line already we are 10 moves deep and
it's not quite clear what's going on
here why does an exchange down but he
has some very substantial compensation
for that
of porn structure um and this is not the
only nine possible by the way white can
also consider to take here immediately
which is which is a bit different a bit
different very complicated stuff
it seems that Bishop c5 was a possible
defense but you you've seen how
complicated those lines are very
difficult to do that over the border and
this was a very very typical situation
for Todd's opponents especially in those
wild years late 50s early 60s where he
was constantly getting into those super
dangerous attacking positions and
players simply weren't yeah they weren't
used to to this kind of super precise
defense and this aggressive way of
playing okay
Bishop d8 Ausmus la smooth not bad
absolutely not he did a good job
initially queen edge for the Queen wants
to get into attacking position towards
the king of course it's a piece a curved
ice takes and Queen g5 here we see a big
difference to the other 998 is here it's
bad here because of just Queen takes the
edge this Bishop is hanging this is not
a defense obviously so what should black
Dumas he played night to h5 this is the
best move looks a bit crazy but the best
move that is available g6 after Knight
h6 track King g7 Janet f5 it's maybe
leading to a draw it's very difficult
now for black and for white sorry after
King g8 to play something better than
Knight h6 very difficult not sure
I mean g6 is a move that you don't like
to play so much because it looks like
weakening weakening
structure but maybe it was okay
another point could be that maybe Smith
sloth was trying to win the game what
not is a piece up yeah so it's not clear
why you should play g6 and allow a
possible repetition by the way after
this track like shouldn't go in the
corner after Bishop c3 the threat of
rook takes d7 is is very very strong
for example Queen a to rook d7 is
winning the game immediately
yeah Knight h5 @ h5 was played yeah what
should white do now yeah the knight is
hanging of course
but if while takes there is Knight f6
and this is simply winning for black
very quickly the tables are turned
the knight is that the queen is attacked
and after something like this oops
g6 White's queen is in trouble for
example something like this is very
strong for black the tech is also
completely over while black is still
attacking the H upon very importantly so
the capture on h5 is not right what
should why do
chata gave the check and only now took
on h5 Queen takes age 5 yeah like no
took on a 2 for counter play not for the
porn queen takes angel and now white
played the office move Bishop c3 this
Bishop master participate in the attack
so we have reached a very very sharp
position of course White has those
attacking forces Bishop on c3 Knight on
h6 Queen on h5 all posted actively
against the King and black really must
be very cautious in defense
what should he plain black still is fine
him he only has to find the right booth
the writings and this position is Bishop
to f6 looks fairly logical trying to
neutralize this this Bishop on c3 how
could it continue yeah more than one way
I'm giving you one possible line Knight
f7 also as possible black just placed
King g8 but 95 is also dangerous looking
at technicals after that black will take
track with a check and now f6 this looks
like a very good defense at first but it
is not as good as it looks
f6 Queen f4 and now what should what
should black play it's important to see
that capturing the night it's not really
good because of rook e1 those moves
those silent moves of the other check
are difficult to see the idea is there's
more than one actually one idea is that
Knight e5 is not working at all due to
rook takes e5 with white winning with
the checkmating attack this defense is
not possible but what should black play
the problem is if he goes back for
example this rookie 7 and this is
impossible to defend there's just too
much going on at the same time something
like this Queen age six to h7 black is
totally paralyzed he's a piss-up
but he really has no defense against
this against this attack all those moves
are difficult to see especially before
and when you're right in the position
you might see them but you have to see
it
much earlier than that black however
after Queen f4 has a defense more than
one actually 95 is a defense that also
is Knight e5 as a possible defending we
can look at 95 at first it looks
ridiculous white can take but black in
fact can ignore it all and just develop
with Bishop e6 quite funny the point is
that if white now moves the bishop and
somewhere here for example then look the
8th as possible an interesting way to
defend 95 Knight c5 however is probably
better or simpler even just not
returning any material here white can
draw with Knight f7 check funny way like
cannot take of course at some made some
King g8 and white again track has a
check with the perpetual if black takes
we have this check and again black must
be cautious you shouldn't step to age 8
track track mate next move you must go
here and then Queen c7 is good enough
for a draw a perpetual check white
always has enough attack to to get at
least a draw but Bishop f6 must be
played he played Knight f6 and if you
don't know the game you might look at
this position treated as a low exercise
what should white play in this position
white to play and you're getting a
decisive attack a direct winner yeah
white wins with 3 takes of some very
very nice move I always want to
sacrifice the Queen of course yeah first
the easy things if black takes the Queen
track we are going to checkmate black
checkmate like this alternatively
checkmate like this
very nice so let cannot take the Queen
what should he do of course their screen
takes f8 threatened so not much choice
like black can basically only give the
check iam Jack King - yeah and now the
funny thing is that of course the Queen
is also attacked so after the route
capture on f7 which was played yeah it's
a it's a check on f7 track and now we
just take the Queen we can take stock
now after King takes Knight jack 95 and
96 why does an exchange and the pawn up
so the whole combination with Queen
takes f7 has led to material gain
exchange at pawn is plenty enough to win
the game we only have a couple of more
moves track gave this cheque King wind
up Jack and Bishop default here smooth
Slav probably very disappointed resigned
the game yeah a typical tower game
sparkling attacks very nice here we have
a situation where in fact black defended
very well up to this point but now
simply I guess correct under the
pressure while I think that the lines
after Bishop f6 not so easy to evaluate
I think it's quite remarkable that the
player of Smith's love strengths
strength after Knight f6 obviously
overlooked Queen takes f7 or maybe
overlooked some line we related to that
but it's all part of Todd some tarts are
playing started he's putting so much
pressure on the opponent that very often
they correct yeah I hope you enjoyed
this game great attacking chess here and
well I'll be back
with other subject classic games and
games stay tuned on this channel thanks
for watching